hey rich and adam my name is sierra i'm
23 years old and i'm currently living
and going to school
in kalamazoo michigan i struggled a lot
with my mental health from a very young
age
at about 12 i was diagnosed with
clinical depression anxiety and i
struggled for a long time
when i got to undergrad i was stable in
my mental health but i realized how bad
my physical health was
i've since lost 50 pounds signed up for
my first marathon this summer
and just hit one year of being
completely plant-based right now i have
a question
regarding my life as it is now i'm
currently struggling with
the complex of quote doing it all i work
about 35 hours a week in retail to pay
my bills
i'm a full-time student and a teaching
assistant at the school
i dedicate at least two hours a day to
practicing my craft of clarinet playing
and i exercise six days a week
i'm often looked up to as a leader in my
role in retail
and at the school i'm often there to
support other people
but i am living alone and halfway across
the country from
my family i can't remember the last time
i had a day to do nothing
and i'm loving what i'm doing but at the
same time
super exhausted um any and all advice
would be welcome and thanks
shout out to sierra in michigan i know
go blue you're killing it um it's such a
good question
i love this question and i think it's
really relevant to what we were talking
about earlier about balance
i agree no it's it's super related to
that that's why i put that in here
mm-hmm good for you curating see what
i'm doing experience
i'm linking based on a theme i'm linking
segments you are i already told you your
job is secure
have you seen my swim mask yeah i have
okay i have
and i didn't did i make fun of you no i
did not
i said we reached into taunt in the oslo
talks
um sierra great question i think this is
a
common predicament for many the first
thought that comes to mind
is is uh
is something i learned in sobriety which
is this idea of the road is always
getting narrower
right so you start out you have these
mental health struggles you seem to get
on top of that
you then set your sights on your
physical health you lose all this weight
you run a marathon it's like i got it
together
but the road continues to narrow and
you're faced
new challenges that force you to
confront yourself
in in in deeper ways like you've done
this
heavy lifting in these other areas and
now this other stuff is showing up and i
think what you're experiencing is
is really common to a lot of people
again it's related to our conversation
about balance very much rooted in that
and i think you know based upon what
you're saying
that your life is not
the way you're living your life right
now is not sustainable
in the long term i think you're doing
what you need to
survive at the moment and pursue your
goals and
and really uh develop your your your
craft and your talent and your passion i
think it's super laudable like mad
respect for everything that you've taken
on everything that you're shouldering
right now to
make all of this happen and i think you
know at 23 you're young you can handle
it for now
but you have taken on a lot and i think
you know you're going to need to really
and it sounds like you're already doing
this like figure out a way to
pursue this path in a more
sustainable way and i suspect
just based upon the way you've described
yourself that you're somebody who has a
predisposition to over deliver and
everything that you do
do you get that sense adam no doubt yeah
yeah she's crushing it
right like she's showing up and killing
it in all these different
areas but i think over time when you
are that kind of person and you shoulder
that kind of responsibility and you
create those expectations with
other people that you're engaged with
it's going to drain the joy out of
everything that you're doing and it will
inevitably lead to
burnout so that's the first thing
i also and tell me what you think adam i
also smell
a little hint of of of codependence in
this
this idea that sierra is over giving of
herself to meet
everyone else's needs like she's she
everybody in the retail job
loves her and she's a ta so she's there
for her students she's showing up
for all these other people at the cost
of her own
well-being which is secondary
so she goes home at night completely
depleted
and lonely because she's living alone
yeah so i think the first thing is
figuring out how to
maybe because she can't do that for her
family because they're far away so it's
a kind of a
sub for that right well i'd be
interested in what the family dynamic is
yeah right like so is she somebody who
in
her rearing with somebody who
showed up for other people in her family
in the same way that she's doing this
for her students and in her retail job i
would suspect that that's
that's likely highly likely yeah right
so here
she is alone doesn't have the family's
support
and doesn't have that outlet for you
know
showing up for other people as she did
you know in the house growing up and
she's doing it in this other way so i
think
i think sierra you need to flip the
script and and first understand
and accept that you can't be everything
to everybody
all the time and as a you know as a
people pleaser myself
i get it but the question really should
be
how do you please yourself and by please
yourself i don't mean that in
in an indulgent or or selfish way but
really
what do you need to make sure that your
needs are being taken care of so that
you're
fit adequately fit to show up
for these other people and in all of
these other areas of your life
there's a great marcus aurelius quote
that i think is relevant to this he said
i have often wondered how it is that
every man loves himself more than all
the rest of men
but yet sets less value on his own
opinion of himself than on the opinion
of others
so again this is a bit of a projection
sierra because i don't know you but it
sounds like
you are somebody who does concern
herself with the opinion of the people
in your retail job and
you know these students that you're ta
like all these different jobs that you
have and you're
coming last in this and as a result
you're suffering so i think
you need to get really clear on what
your main priorities are
first and foremost figure out a way so
that you can
focus on that and learn to be okay with
imperfection
in your other areas especially in
regards to these less important facets
of your life like you're re like i
presume that you're not pursuing a
career in retail you're trying to become
this unbelievable
clarinet performer right so how can you
and it's tough like these are real life
problems you got to pay your bills
you're working two jobs you're a
full-time student like
this is not an easy equation to solve so
the last thing i want to do is come
across
as like pithy with all of this because
it's very difficult
but i do think a process
or a strategy for tackling this is to
a do an honest inventory of everything
that you do
literally get a notepad or a mole scan
and journal how you spend your time in
15 minute increments do that over
a week and i think you'll get
an objective picture on how you're
actually spending your time
there probably will be surprising areas
where
you're spending more time doing
something than you originally thought
that you
were that will give you a launch pad to
then
evaluate what it is that
you could possibly let go of or
de-escalate
and other areas of your life that are
not getting the adequate amount of
attention
and give you a roadmap for how you could
perhaps
simplify your life like if your life is
so crowded and so complicated that
you're going from one thing to the next
thing to the next thing to the next
thing
never really having the bandwidth to
invest in any self-care
whatsoever and then just coming home and
crashing
you know that's not a great life plan
and as somebody who's trying to
cultivate
a creative talent you need that
nurturing time
in order to really connect with the best
of what you have to offer with respect
to this art form that you're pursuing
you just can't succeed in life you can't
succeed
in your goals unless you take care of
yourself first
and you actually can't adequately take
care of all these other people that
you're trying to take care of right now
unless you take care of yourself
first so approach it not from the
perspective of that being indulgent or
selfish
but actually necessary in terms of you
optimizing
the opportunity that you have right now
to step into becoming this artist
100 what do you think i think you nailed
it i think
[Music]
you know prioritizing where you can find
time for yourself is going to be key
to because it's a long haul to become
great
and master of a craft like the clarinet
and and you need to
you can't afford to burn out no and a
lot of musicians do because it's
so competitive and and and and it's
sometimes
the satisfaction you get of doing a good
job at a retail job
is more readily it comes to you easier
right you'll get the validation
immediately yeah yeah yeah yeah
or as a leader in whatever that's why a
lot of people
take certain jobs because they're
elevated as leaders right away and
leadership
can be fulfilling because you're helping
people achieve
something so she's on the grind though
this it reminds me of law school like
when you're that age you can
you can do it yeah and you could do it
for a while yeah you know you could do
it like i couldn't do that now
i would you know collapse but when
you're 23 you're robust you can handle
it
but i just think it's it's a time in
your life where you have an opportunity
to develop healthier life skills
around these things and you really need
to protect what's most important to you
100 percent
[Music]
you